[Music]  hey  you okay there jesus  i think i hurt someone this is ed warren  here with lorraine all right let's get  started  residents of brookfield were shocked  this afternoon by the broad daylight  murder of bruno sauls  the court accepts the existence of god  every time a witness swears to tell the  truth  i think it's about time they accept the  existence of the devil  whatever was going on whatever happened  that day that was not  it's a witch's totem we think your  family was cursed  and that connection is still open  i'm only interested in reality  but i can see things that your people  can't  [Music]  something terrible happened here  a master satanist is not an adversary to  be taken likely  him worth everything you have  because that's what an affair will cost  all right  [Music]  foreign